Katrina:  酒量测试开始
Katrina: Drinking capacity test begins
Lucia: 这个是不是
Lucia: Is this...
Katrina:  能拿厨房湿巾吗
Katrina: Can we get the kitchen wipes?
Jake: 这要不放下面洗
Jake: How about we wash it below?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Tasha: 就就在这洗吧
Tasha: Just wash it here
Lucia: 对哦拿厨房湿巾擦一遍可能会
Lucia: Yeah, using kitchen wipes might be
Lucia: 更方便洗一些
Lucia: more convenient to clean
Jake:还还能用
Jake: It can still be used
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia: 这能先擦一遍吗
Lucia: Can we wipe it first?
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one
Tasha: 这个不用待会直接洗洁精洗就行了
Tasha: No need, just use dish soap later
Lucia: 啊那也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too
Lucia: 感觉里面很多渣
Lucia: It feels like there's a lot of residue inside
Lucia: 有的把它先弄出来
Lucia: Let's get it out first
Lucia: 刚那个不是有点
Lucia: Didn't it just have a bit
Lucia: 稍微有点
Lucia: a bit
Lucia: 那个啥有点堵
Lucia: kind of clogged?
Tasha: 喝一口啊
Tasha: Take a sip
Tasha: 这汤好鲜美啊
Tasha: This soup is so delicious
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 你确实
Tasha: You sure
Shure:  我给你们打call
Shure: I'm cheering for you guys
Lucia: 这个把他拿过去
Lucia: Take this over there
Katrina:  你喝什么呢
Katrina: What are you drinking?
Lucia: 这个在这边放一下这是要洗的
Lucia: Let's put this here, it needs to be washed
Katrina:  不要了
Katrina: No need
Katrina:  再那个我都害怕
Katrina: I'm so scared to try it again
Shure:  你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  哈哈他妈的
Shure: Haha, damn it
Jake: 谢谢您哎
Jake: Thank you so much
Alice: 没事这可能是他的陈年污渍
Alice: No problem, it might be old stains
Lucia: 对擦了擦感觉掉不了
Lucia: Yeah, it feels like it won't come off even after wiping
Lucia: 不管他那个了
Lucia: Never mind
Tasha: 你看还好买了一包吧
Tasha: Good thing we bought a pack
Lucia: 我们这别的
Lucia: We have other stuff here
Lucia: 这个这个锅吗
Lucia: Is it this pot?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah
Lucia: 我也我也不太确定
Lucia: I’m not really sure either.
Alice: 这是我们的还是这的
Alice: Is this ours or theirs?
Lucia: 这些锅应该都是这儿的
Lucia: These pots should all be theirs.
Alice: 那放二楼吧
Alice: Then put them on the second floor.
Tasha: 洗碗这个活没有人愿意接受
Tasha: Nobody wants to take the dishwashing job.
Jake: 确实
Jake: True.
Lucia: 啊sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Shure:  我觉得
Shure: I think...
Shure:  是时候拿出吉他了
Shure: It’s time to bring out the guitar.
Alice: 来防一下锅
Alice: Let’s protect the pots.
Tasha: 嗯放这吧
Tasha: Yeah, let’s put it here.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 那我把这个也放进去吧
Lucia: I’ll put this in too.
Lucia: 给你增加一点工作量
Lucia: Just to give you a bit more work.
Shure:  洗手间
Shure: Restroom.
Shure:  帅老师不喜欢回归大自然吗
Shure: Doesn’t Mr. Shuai like returning to nature?
Lucia: 这就放地下算了
Lucia: Let’s just leave it on the floor.
Lucia: 那个板可以拿来立着
Lucia: You can stand the board up.
Lucia: 纸擦一擦
Lucia: Wipe it with a paper towel.
Tasha: 但是我没喝完嘛
Tasha: But I haven’t finished drinking.
Alice: 那我给你留这了啊
Alice: I’ll leave it here for you then.
Tasha: 好行
Tasha: Okay, sure.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure:  你喝吗啊
Shure: Are you drinking it?
Tasha: 我喝呢
Tasha: I’m drinking it.
Shure: 你真喝吗
Shure: Are you really drinking it?
Tasha: 真喝呢
Tasha: Yes, I am.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 你喝一杯应该没关系吧
Tasha: One drink shouldn’t be a problem, right?
Shure:  喝一杯他
Shure: One drink is...
Shure:  他毫无关系
Shure: It’s totally fine.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 醋放下边
Alice: Put the vinegar down below.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Shure:  没事这这这柜里还有3瓶呢
Shure: No worries, there are three more bottles in the cupboard.
Tasha: 可以竖着放
Tasha: You can store it vertically.
Lucia: 啊对不起对不起啊
Lucia: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 刚那个有点使劲好像水崩起来了
Lucia: I used too much force and the water splashed.
Lucia: 没有溅到你们身上吧
Lucia: Didn't splash on you guys, right?
Jake: 好油啊
Jake: So oily
Tasha: 没关系这只是洗第一
Tasha: No worries, this is just the first wash
Tasha: 遍还有洗第二遍的
Tasha: We still have a second wash
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 好油啊
Tasha: So oily
Lucia: 台子旁边
Lucia: Next to the counter
Lucia: 等一会洗完了再擦吧
Lucia: Let's wipe it after washing
Tasha: 你把它放到油碗里
Tasha: Put it in the oil bowl
Tasha: 好油呀他变的呵呵
Tasha: It's so oily, haha
Lucia: 还有啥别的呢
Lucia: Anything else?
Lucia: 这些线先拆下来
Lucia: Let's remove these wires first
Tasha: 买一个小碗洗碗机吧
Tasha: Let's buy a small dishwasher
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们有硕
Jake: We have Shure
Alice: 还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Tasha: 硕硕
Tasha: Shure
Jake: 来一轮
Jake: Come on
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: No more
Alice: 没了
Alice: No more
Lucia: 这个可以当垃圾袋用
Lucia: This can be used as a trash bag
Lucia: 因为里面扔了很多
Lucia: Because there's a lot inside
Shure:  what's up bro
Shure: What's up bro
Tasha: 让你买个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to buy a dishwasher
Jake:让你当个洗碗机
Jake: I told you to be a dishwasher
Tasha: 让你当个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to be a dishwasher
Shure:  让我买个洗碗机
Shure: You want me to buy a dishwasher
Jake: 买个是难
Jake: Buying one is hard
Tasha: 让你当一个洗碗机
Tasha: I told you to be a dishwasher
Shure: 什么买个洗碗机
Shure: What, buy a dishwasher
Jake: 当个洗碗机
Jake: Be a dishwasher
Shure:  我靠买个洗碗机
Shure: Oh man, buy a dishwasher
Shure:  真的吗bro
Shure: Really bro
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright
Tasha: 堵住了你有没有发现需要您清理
Tasha: It's clogged, did you notice? You need to clean it
Tasha: 这筷子洗的
Tasha: These chopsticks are washed
Lucia: 那我把这拿下去
Lucia: I'll take this downstairs
Tasha: 真有水平
Tasha: Really skillful
Shure:  跟洗跟没洗的一样
Shure: It's like it wasn't even washed
Tasha: 你看他这个筷子洗的
Tasha: Look at how he washed these chopsticks
Tasha: 洗成两坨了
Tasha: It's become two lumps after washing.
Shure:  然后先让他水流下去
Shure: Let the water flow down first.
Jake:我这先搁哪呢
Jake: Where should I put this first?
Shure:  你随便搁哪都行
Shure: You can put it anywhere you like.
Shure:  然后我搅一会就行
Shure: I'll just stir it for a while.
Shure:  你别搁搁地漏上就行
Shure: Just don't put it on the drain.
Jake: 我先去洗洗手去
Jake: I'll go wash my hands first.
Shure:  哎愁死了
Shure: Ugh, this is so frustrating.
Lucia: 这袋子先放这扔垃圾的
Lucia: Let's put this bag here for trash.
Lucia: 扔满了再拿下去
Lucia: We'll take it down when it's full.
Tasha: 哈哈哈洗碗机成功
Tasha: Hahaha, the dishwasher worked!
Shure:  ai看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
Shure:  就是人类搅一圈之后
Shure: After a person stirs it,
Shure:  手上会有这么多油
Shure: There's so much oil on their hand.
Shure:  你记住了吗
Shure: Did you remember that?
Lucia: 你记住了吗
Lucia: Did you remember that?
Shure:  侮辱杨老板的数据石吧
Shure: Disgrace to Jake's data stone, huh?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god,
Tasha: 这越洗越油
Tasha: The more I wash, the oilier it gets.
Tasha: 不要用另一只手摸他了
Tasha: Don't touch it with the other hand.
Lucia: 你拿这个擦一擦
Lucia: Use this to wipe it off.
Lucia: 可以去油应该
Lucia: It should remove the oil.
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Alice: 这洗好了吗
Alice: Is this clean now?
Tasha: 这还要再冲一遍呢
Tasha: It needs to be rinsed again.
Tasha: 这只用洗洁精抹了一遍
Tasha: I just used dish soap once.
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 刚洗的手
Alice: Just washed my hands.
Tasha: 你经常干这个活啊
Tasha: Do you do this often?
Tasha: 把里面的渣渣能不能捞出来
Tasha: Can you scoop out the residue inside?
Shure:  咱过四五天呢哥
Shure: We have about four or five days, bro.
Tasha: 要不以后别用楼上的厨房了
Tasha: Maybe we shouldn't use the upstairs kitchen anymore.
Shure: 要不以后别用厨房了都点外卖
Shure: Or maybe we should just order takeout instead.
Shure: 咱买一次性的锅
Shure: We could buy disposable pots.
Tasha:还有一次性的锅这种说法
Tasha: There's such a thing as disposable pots?
Shure:  有那锡纸锅两块钱一个哈哈
Shure: Yeah, those aluminum foil pots, two bucks each, haha.
Tasha: 你就是专业干这个的呀
Tasha: You really are a pro at this.
Tasha: 怪不得喊你来当洗碗机呢
Tasha: No wonder they call you the dishwasher.
Lucia: 这边我觉得还是
Lucia: I still think this...
Tasha: 需要帮忙吗
Tasha: Need any help?
Lucia: 等过会擦吧
Lucia: Let's clean it later.
Lucia: 这太高了吧
Lucia: This is too high.
Lucia: 放下来一点
Lucia: Lower it a bit.
Tasha: 这个还要再冲一遍了
Tasha: This needs another rinse.
Alice: 你手串是开过光的吗
Alice: Is your bracelet blessed?
Alice: 你那手串开过光吗
Shure:  没有女朋友随便送我的
Shure: No, my girlfriend just gave it to me casually.
Tasha: 肯定是他不要的哈哈哈
Tasha: It must be something he didn't want, haha.
Shure:  我就你会说话是不是
Shure: You really know how to talk, don't you?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  你信不信我这这盘子抡你脑袋上
Shure: Do you believe I'll smash this plate on your head?
Tasha: 你说随便送东西的
Tasha: You said it was casually given.
Tasha: 肯定是她淘汰下来的货
Tasha: It must be something she didn't want anymore.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  因为我平时平时穿粉色衣服多
Shure: It's because I usually wear pink clothes.
Shure:  然后送我一个粉色手串
Shure: So she gave me a pink bracelet.
Tasha: 哦你早说嘛
Tasha: Oh, you should have said so.
Tasha: 是她特地送给你的不就行了
Tasha: She gave it to you specifically, that's fine.
Tasha: 你为什么说是随便送给你的
Tasha: Why did you say it was casually given?
Alice: 要轻描淡写过去这个话题哈哈哈
Alice: Just brush off this topic casually, haha.
Tasha: 然后还说要打我
Tasha: And then he said he wanted to hit me.
Lucia: 好像嗯我把这个扔了吧
Lucia: It seems, um, I'll throw this away.
Lucia: 在站一会没抓到什么可以擦的东西
Lucia: Standing here, I can't find anything to clean.
Shure:  把杯子先都刷出来了
Shure: Wash all the cups first.
Lucia: 呃哪个
Lucia: Uh, which one?
Shure:  啊对于喝酒
Shure: Ah, it's important for drinking.
Shure:  来说很重要所以要都刷出来
Shure: So we need to wash them all.
Lucia: 这没杯子吗
Lucia: Aren't there any cups?
Shure:  这本来就有杯子
Shure: There were cups originally.
Shure:  咱们都使完了你知道吗
Shure: We used them all, you know?
Lucia: 不是我是说
Lucia: No, I mean,
Lucia: 就是我没看到有刷完需要擦的杯子
Lucia: I didn't see any that needed wiping after washing.
Lucia: 就是你这不是正刷着吗
Lucia: I mean, aren't you washing them now?
Shure:  行了我刷了我刷了
Shure: Alright, I'll wash them, I'll wash them.
Shure:  哎呦呦呦呦
Shure: Oh my gosh.
Shure:  帮我拿点谢谢
Shure: Help me get some, thanks.
Shure:  愁死了
Shure: This is so stressful.
Shure:  什什么喝完酒还要刷杯子呀
Shure: What, we have to wash the cups after drinking?
Shure:  卧槽这是
Shure: Damn, this is...
Alice: 啊这还有俩锅
Alice: Ah, there are two more pots here.
Shure:  杨老板给我结double工资
Shure: Jake, give me double the salary.
Shure:  不然话我不干了杨老板
Shure: Or else I quit, Jake.
Tasha: 这可不是你能决定的
Tasha: That's not for you to decide.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我把这碗拿下拿到楼下刷一下算了
Lucia: I'll just take this bowl downstairs and wash it.
Shure:  这碗不是刷完的吗
Shure: Wasn't this bowl already washed?
Lucia: 不是要再涮一遍吗
Lucia: Doesn't it need to be washed again?
Tasha: 再冲一遍就行了
Tasha: Just rinse it again, it's fine.
Shure: 你哎
Shure: Hey, you...
Lucia: 不是有
Lucia: Isn't there...
Tasha: 拿下去
Tasha: Take it down.
Choiszt:  哎再再给我用一下
Choiszt: Hey, let me use it again.
Tasha: 旁边还有洗洁精吗
Tasha: Is there any dish soap left?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey...
Lucia: 这哪边热水哪边凉水
Lucia: Which side is hot water and which side is cold?
Shure:  听过
Shure: I've heard of it.
Katrina:  哎哎我这平板那个音效特好
Katrina: Hey, hey, the sound on my tablet is amazing.
Katrina:  4个
Katrina: Four speakers.
Katrina: 买来听歌
Katrina: Bought it just for listening to music.
Katrina:  学习一点没干
Katrina: Haven't done any studying at all.
Lucia: 哎这从
Lucia: Hey, this...
Lucia: 哦这从有抹布
Lucia: Oh, there's a cloth here.
Katrina:  我靠跟音响一样
Katrina: Wow, it's like a speaker!
Shure:  走去楼下听去
Shure: Come on, let's go listen downstairs.
Katrina:  楼下咋了
Katrina: What's up with downstairs?
Katrina:  PK一下你的音响跟我的平板吗
Katrina: You want to compare your speakers with my tablet?
Shure:  开玩笑那两个独立单元跟你这个比
Shure: Are you kidding me? Those two units can't compare with yours.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我这一个这一个
Katrina: Haha, just one, just one.
Shure:  喝点嘛喝点嘛
Shure: Have a drink, have a drink.
Katrina:  又想套我话是不是哈哈哈
Katrina: Trying to get me to talk, right? Haha.
Shure:  喝点喝点来来来
Shure: Have a drink, come on, come on.
Katrina: 不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  今天晚上还有东西要干呢
Katrina: I still have things to do tonight.
Shure:  我24号交毕设
Shure: My project is due on the 24th.
Shure:  你几号交毕设
Shure: When's yours due?
Katrina:  你论文写完了吗
Katrina: Have you finished your thesis?
Shure:  写差不多了
Shure: Almost done.
Katrina:  呀怎么切了呀给我
Katrina: Why did it cut off? Give it to me.
Katrina:  这什么老歌
Katrina: What is this old song?
Katrina:  林志炫的
Katrina: Lin Zhixuan's
Katrina:  我要去把楼下那个to do list写一下
Katrina: I'm going downstairs to write the to-do list.
Shure:  to do list是吗
Shure: The to-do list, right?
Katrina:  明天
Katrina: For tomorrow.
Lucia: 我靠嘞
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Katrina:  成为一个自带BGM的女生
Katrina: Become a girl with her own BGM.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Shure:  杨老板我们什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: Jake, when are we going to clean the room?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Alice: 好大的油味
Alice: Such a strong oil smell.
Lucia: 对这个怎么处理我也在想
Lucia: Yeah, I'm also wondering how to handle this.
Alice:洗洁精
Alice: Dish soap.
Lucia: 碗反正现在都搞了
Lucia: Anyway, I've already dealt with the dishes.
Alice: 这些都好了
Alice: These are done.
Alice:那我放进去了
Alice: I'll put them in.
Lucia: 主要咱还有俩锅
Lucia: We still have two more pots.
Alice: 哎呦妈呀
Alice: Oh my goodness.
Alice:这个刷了吗
Alice: Did you scrub this?
Lucia: 呃我不知道
Lucia: Uh, I don't know.
Lucia: 因为我只刷了第二遍的那个碗
Lucia: Because I only scrubbed the bowl for the second time.
Lucia: 这个我也不清楚不清楚是谁洗的这个也要
Lucia: I'm not sure who cleaned this, it needs another round.
Lucia: 再弄一遍
Lucia: Or else...
Lucia: 要不把它再
Lucia: Just wipe it.
Lucia: 擦就算了你看这
Lucia: Look at this.
Lucia: 都没那啥
Lucia: It's not clean at all.
Lucia: 我刚把手擦干算了没事
Lucia: I just dried my hands, never mind.
Alice: 我现在没有
Alice: I don't have...
Alice: 我们现在没有那个洗洁精了这会
Alice: We don't have any dish soap right now.
Lucia: 拿下去了是吗
Lucia: Did you take it down?
Lucia: 呃那这是
Lucia: Uh, this is...
Lucia: 这是啥这是油污净
Lucia: What is this? Is this grease remover?
Lucia: 这是不是可以用来洗那个啥
Lucia: Can this be used to clean the...
Lucia: 洗这个
Lucia: Clean this?
Lucia: 洗这个池子
Lucia: Clean the sink.
Alice: 清洁除胶
Alice: Cleaning and glue remover.
Alice: 这个是可以弄这个的
Alice: This can be used for that.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Right, right.
Lucia: 洗池子碗应该不行
Lucia: For the sink, not for the dishes.
Lucia: 碗估计是不行
Lucia: Probably not for the dishes.
Alice:这还没拆开呢
Alice: This one hasn't been opened yet.
Lucia: 这个碗看起来也不怎么干净样子
Lucia: This bowl doesn't look very clean either.
Lucia: 要不把他洗了算了
Lucia: How about we just wash it?
Lucia: 这个嘞
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 这怎么一捏就是油的呀
Lucia: Why does it feel oily as soon as you squeeze it?
Alice: 今天几点结束呢
Alice: What time do we finish today?
Tasha: 好像说很快
Tasha: I heard it will be soon.
Tasha: 等录完房间就结束了
Tasha: Once we finish recording the room, we're done.
Alice:不还要交换礼物吗
Alice: Aren't we exchanging gifts too?
Lucia: 歇一下
Lucia: Let's take a break.
Tasha: 歇会吧
Tasha: Yeah, let's rest for a bit.
Tasha: 他们都开始在楼下唱歌了
Tasha: They're already singing downstairs.
Alice: 但是这剩下来的那个什么还没清洁呢
Alice: But the remaining stuff hasn't been cleaned yet.
Lucia: 我在想这个锅
Lucia: I'm thinking about this pot.
Lucia: 这锅看起来太大了
Lucia: This pot looks too big.
Lucia: 感觉都放不到那里边这怎么弄
Lucia: It feels like it won't fit in there, what should we do?
Alice:洗洁精是不是也下去了
Alice: Did the dish soap run out too?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:怎么说这锅原来在哪来着
Alice: By the way, where was this pot originally?
Alice:上边还是下边
Alice: Upstairs or downstairs?
Tasha: 在下面但是也可以放上面
Tasha: It can go underneath, but you can also put it on top.
Tasha: 放哪都行其实
Tasha: Actually, it doesn't matter where you put it.
Alice: 好累呀
Alice: I'm so tired.
Tasha: 这是真唱吗
Tasha: Is this a live performance?
Lucia: 是在放音乐吧
Lucia: They’re probably just playing music.
Lucia: 应该是在放音乐
Lucia: They should be playing music.
Lucia: 我们接下来要干嘛呀
Lucia: What are we doing next?
Lucia: 扫房子吗
Lucia: Are we cleaning the house?
Tasha: 哈哈在楼上摸鱼
Tasha: Haha, slacking off upstairs.
Lucia: 想躺下我确实想躺下了
Lucia: I really want to lie down.
Tasha: 他女朋友送他手串怎么不带了
Tasha: His girlfriend gave him a bracelet, why isn't he wearing it?
Alice:是他女朋友送的吗
Alice: Did his girlfriend give it to him?
Alice: ：他不说女生吗
Alice: Didn't he say it was a girl?
Lucia: 他刚不是说女朋友
Lucia: Didn't he just say girlfriend?
Tasha: 对啊啊
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: 啊女朋友吗
Alice: Oh, girlfriend?
Lucia: 那可能就是这个对话发生的时候
Lucia: Maybe you weren't there during that conversation.
Lucia: 你不在
Lucia: You might have missed it.
Lucia: 你可能没有听到
Lucia: You probably didn't hear it.
Alice: 我就听见一个女生朋友随便送的
Alice: I just heard a girl friend casually gave it to him.
Alice:交换礼物是抽吗我会抽到谁呢
Alice: Are we drawing names for the gift exchange? I wonder who I'll get.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Alice:小礼物
Alice: A little gift.
Lucia: 我发现快递到咱们这还挺慢的我现在在想
Lucia: I noticed the delivery to our place is quite slow. I'm wondering...
Lucia: 我东西现在下单还能不能到
Lucia: If I order now, will it still arrive?
Lucia: 因为我有好些还没还没那什么
Lucia: Because I have quite a few that haven't... you know.
Alice: 我们都还没有买
Alice: None of us have bought anything yet.
Lucia: 我光挑了对我今天光挑了一下
Lucia: I just picked out things today, just browsing.
Lucia: 加了好些购物车但是都没有那个啥
Lucia: Added a lot to the cart but didn't actually buy anything.
Alice: 明天是不是要录麻将
Alice: Are we recording mahjong tomorrow?
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha: 感觉每天都会说
Tasha: Feels like we say it every day.
Tasha: 但是每天都不执行
Tasha: But we never actually do it.
Tasha: 因为感觉大家都很难启动的样子
Tasha: Because it seems like everyone is hard to get started.
Lucia: 大家都是p人
Lucia: Everyone's just procrastinating.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我昨天本来想着口红今天就要讨论
Lucia: I was thinking we discuss the lipstick today.
Lucia: 出大概装修成什么样
Lucia: And how the renovation would look.
Lucia: 然后今天就要开始下单了
Lucia: Then we would start ordering today.
Lucia: 但今天好像也没有讨
Lucia: But we haven't discussed specifics.
Lucia: 就是具体的讨论我也没发
Lucia: I haven't figured out what I want.
Lucia: 我也没想到对我也没想到自己要弄成什么样
Lucia: I didn't expect I'd need to figure out what I want it to look like.
Alice:四五六周日不就happy了
Alice: Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday, we’ll be happy.
Alice: 嗯周周一啊
Alice: Yeah, on Monday.
Alice: 这这几天挺快的
Alice: These days are going by quickly.
Alice: 好烫好难受
Alice: It's so hot, so uncomfortable.
Lucia: 所以他如果周日才到的话就很紧张
Lucia: So if it arrives on Sunday, it’ll be stressful.
Lucia: 必须要周六的时候到
Lucia: It has to arrive on Saturday.
Lucia: 但是今天已经17号了我承认明天181920
Lucia: But today is already the 17th. Tomorrow is the 18th, 19th, 20th...
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Lucia: 哈喽
Lucia: Hello.
Alice: 还有两个锅
Alice: There are still two pots left.
Tasha: 就只剩两个锅了
Tasha: Only two pots left.
Tasha: 也已经挺干净的了
Tasha: They're already quite clean.
Lucia: 池子
Lucia: The sink.
Jake: 还是
Jake: Still...
Alice:池子用这个就行了
Alice: Just use this for the sink.
Lucia: 对池子可以用油污净
Lucia: Yeah, the sink can use the grease cleaner.
Lucia: 但是我但是我在想那个锅
Lucia: But I’m thinking about the pots.
Lucia: 因为那锅好像放不进来
Lucia: Because the pots don’t seem to fit.
Jake:哦就是准备泡一泡是吧还是啥
Jake: Oh, are you planning to soak them or what?
Alice: 这个就全是清洁吗
Alice: Is this just for cleaning?
Jake: 那锅能擦干净吗
Jake: Can that pot be cleaned?
Lucia: 这个应该不能洗锅这只能洗
Lucia: This can't be used to wash the pot, it can only wash
Alice:这个只能用来擦厨房表面
Alice: This can only be used to wipe kitchen surfaces.
Lucia: 现在现在洗洁精好像在楼下是吧
Lucia: Right now, the dish soap is downstairs, right?
Lucia:就这个锅他
Lucia: Just this pot, it
Lucia: 感觉非常的宽
Lucia: Feels really wide.
Lucia: 看是
Lucia: Look, it is.
Lucia: 当然也可以勉强这样子一下
Lucia: Of course, we can barely manage it like this.
Lucia: 就就是他对不太准
Lucia: It's just not precise.
Lucia: 那个什么
Lucia: That thing
Lucia: 擦咱能把它擦明白吗
Lucia: Can we wipe it clean?
Jake:试试
Jake: Try it.
Lucia: 我直接把这个拿过去擦一些上面这个
Lucia: I'll just take this and wipe some of it off.
Lucia: 把它擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it a bit.
Lucia: 然后直接用水冲冲就完事了
Lucia: Then just rinse it with water, and that's it.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 可以吗
Lucia: Can we do that?
Lucia: 这上面妈呀我靠
Lucia: On top of this, oh my gosh.
Alice: 这个都洗好了
Alice: This is all washed.
Lucia: 我觉得好像也能擦个七七八八
Lucia: I think we can wipe it about 70-80% clean.
Lucia: 就是有点费纸
Lucia: But it wastes a lot of paper.
Lucia: 我们是不是不应该说那个Fword
Lucia: Should we not say the F-word?
Lucia: 哈哈哈没有没有
Lucia: Haha, no, no.
Lucia: 我刚才感叹了一句
Lucia: I just exclaimed.
Lucia: 那个f word
Lucia: The F-word.
Lucia: 但是我们是不是不能说那个fword
Lucia: But should we not say the F-word?
Lucia: 会被和谐
Lucia: We'll get censored.
Tasha: 和谐就和谐
Tasha: If we get censored, we get censored.
Lucia: 自带一声哔
Lucia: Comes with its own beep.
Lucia: 那电影里面出现fword的时候都会
Lucia: In movies when the F-word appears, they always
Lucia: 消音
Lucia: Silence it.
Tasha: 消音
Tasha: Silence it.
Lucia: 这个要把他弄得太麻烦了
Lucia: This is too much trouble to deal with.
Lucia: 再拿一张算了
Lucia: Let's just get another one.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: So tiring.
Lucia: 这真的很勉强
Lucia: This is really a stretch.
Alice:我觉得还是得用洗洁精
Alice: I think we still need to use dish soap.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: that's crazy
Lucia: That's crazy.
Alice: 你把它拿上来
Alice: Bring it up here.
Lucia: 也行啊
Lucia: Sure thing.
Lucia: 拿洗洁精
Lucia: Get the dish soap.
Lucia: 还是拿洗洁精算了这锅什么的这么大咱要把两个搬下去吗
Lucia: Maybe just get the dish soap. The pot is so big, do we really want to carry both down?
Alice:那我下去拿吧
Alice: I'll go down and get it then.
Lucia: 这个要纯粹用这个还是擦太难擦
Lucia: Do we need to use just this? It's really hard to clean.
Alice:你的无菌手套在哪
Alice: Where are your sterile gloves?
Tasha: 在那个冰箱上
Tasha: On top of the fridge.
Jake: 擦完了
Jake: Done cleaning.
Lucia: 还没有
Lucia: Not yet.
Lucia: 没有这个要纯粹用它擦干净太难擦了
Lucia: It's really hard to clean with just this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我把那边那个
Lucia: I'll get the other one.
Lucia: 这大概花了三四张纸然后擦出来的
Lucia: It took about three or four sheets to clean it.
Lucia: 虽然比刚开始干净多了
Lucia: It's much cleaner than before.
Lucia: 但是没有那个啥那么干净
Lucia: But it's still not as clean as it could be.
Jake: 我现在要扫一遍房间
Jake: I need to sweep the room now.
Jake: 我在想什么时候扫比较方便
Jake: I'm thinking about when's the best time to sweep.
Lucia: 我已经收拾的差不多了
Lucia: I've almost finished tidying up.
Jake: 好
Jake: Good.
Jake: OK行
Jake: Okay, great.
Tasha: 然后我们要干嘛
Tasha: So what are we doing next?
Jake: 你们在下面聊聊
Jake: You guys can chat downstairs.
Jake: 礼物你们怎么互送抓阄还是
Jake: How are you exchanging gifts? Drawing lots or what?
Lucia: 我都可以我是一个什么都可以的p人
Lucia: I'm okay with anything. I'm a whatever person.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Tasha: 我想不到好的办法
Tasha: I can't think of a good way.
Lucia: 大家有什么idea吗哈哈
Lucia: Anyone have any ideas? Haha.
Jake: 摇骰子吧
Jake: How about rolling dice?
Tasha: 谁大谁先挑
Tasha: Whoever rolls higher gets to pick first.
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Alice:挑啥呀
Alice: Pick what?
Tasha: 挑礼物摇骰子
Tasha: Gifts, roll the dice.
Alice:挑礼物
Alice: Pick gifts.
Lucia: 鉴于我的礼物是个小choker
Lucia: Since my gift is a small choker,
Lucia: 所以我认为男生如果抽到的话
Lucia: I think if a guy gets it,
Lucia: 并没有什么用处
Lucia: it's not very useful.
Tasha: choker
Tasha: A choker?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 这样吧你们下去聊聊明天的计划
Jake: Alright, you guys go downstairs and talk about tomorrow's plan.
Lucia: 明天干嘛
Lucia: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow we’re going outdoors.
Tasha: 户外
Tasha: Outdoors?
Jake: 采采风
Jake: To enjoy nature.
Tasha: 采什么风
Tasha: Enjoy what?
Jake: 拍拍照片
Jake: Take some photos.
Jake: 玩一玩
Jake: Have some fun.
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yep.
Lucia: 游客照吗
Lucia: Like tourist photos?
Tasha: 野餐吗
Tasha: A picnic?
Jake: 呃最后一天可能放点短片什么的
Jake: Uh, on the last day we might show some short films or something.
Jake: 结果好像也没有
Jake: But it seems like we don’t have any.
Jake: 什么剧本
Jake: Any scripts.
Lucia: 不是您不是有个剧本吗
Lucia: Don't you have a script?
Tasha: 您不是有个备用剧本吗
Tasha: Don’t you have a backup script?
Tasha: 那要不我们现在找一个剧本
Tasha: How about we find a script now?
Tasha: 然后我们开演吧
Tasha: And start acting it out?
Lucia: 对就我们可以找一个相对比较现相对比较现成的
Lucia: Yeah, we could find something relatively ready to go.
Lucia: 你知道韩国有一个
Lucia: You know, in Korea, there's a
Lucia: 有一个团就是类似于哔哩哔哩上面那种小
Lucia: There's a group, kind of like those short clips on Bilibili
Lucia: 短片的那么一个团队
Lucia: A team that makes those
Lucia: 他们是就是
Lucia: So, we’ve been
Lucia: 既然我们最近几天
Lucia: Discussing MBTI stuff
Lucia: 一直在讨论MBTI的事情
Lucia: A lot these days
Lucia: 就他们是就是就是一直在做一些就是
Lucia: So they keep making these
Lucia: 呃通
Lucia: Uh, short
Lucia: 就是这种MBTI的这种小情景短剧
Lucia: MBTI-related skits
Tasha: 小什么
Tasha: Short what?
Lucia: 就是情景短句
Lucia: Like short skits
Lucia: 就是比如说比如说你是假设你是你是
Lucia: For example, if you're, let's say
Lucia: 你是j人
Lucia: 然后我是p人
Lucia: If you're a J-type
Lucia: 然后我们俩比如说在讨论某个问题
Lucia: And I'm a P-type
Lucia: 然后就是j人可能就是呃呃
Lucia: And we're discussing a certain topic
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: The J-type might have a certain perspective
Lucia: 然后p人
Lucia: And the P-type
Lucia: 大概率会有什么什么样的看法
Lucia: 对就是但是他是以一种就是
Lucia: Yeah, but he's doing it in a way that's...
Lucia: 不是那么很刻板和学术
Lucia: Not too stereotypical or academic.
Lucia: 他确实会有一个语境
Lucia: He definitely has a context.
Lucia: 比如说啊
Lucia: Like, for example,
Lucia: 我们三个围在一起吃火锅啊什么的
Lucia: the three of us are gathered around eating hotpot or something.
Lucia: 然后突然聊到什么问题
Lucia: Then suddenly we talk about something.
Lucia: 然后比如说就是
Lucia: And for example,
Lucia: 就是因为
Lucia: like because
Lucia: 比如说那个今天的月亮好圆啊
Lucia: for example, "The moon is so full tonight."
Lucia: 不是表白的时候经常用的一句话吗
Lucia: Isn't that a common phrase used in confessions?
Lucia: 或者什么
Lucia: Or something like,
Lucia: 我想跟你看今天的月亮怎么怎么样
Lucia: "I want to watch the moon with you tonight."
Lucia: 然后就是如果是t人的话
Lucia: So if it's a T person,
Lucia: 就会觉得啊
Lucia: they might think,
Lucia: 为什么要说这句话
Lucia: "Why would you say that?"
Lucia: 然后如果是f人的话
Lucia: But if it's an F person,
Lucia: 就会很快get到
Lucia: they would quickly get it.
Lucia: 然后觉得啊好浪漫什么的这种
Lucia: And think, "Oh, that's so romantic," or something like that.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后那个还挺有意思的
Lucia: And that's quite interesting.
Lucia: 就是如果有
Lucia: If there are,
Lucia: 比如说有类似的这样的剧本的话
Lucia: for example, similar scripts like that,
Lucia: 我们可以按照他随便演一下
Lucia: we can just act them out casually.
Lucia: 就
Lucia: Like,
Lucia: 如果我们实在找不到什么别的XTV
Lucia: if we really can't find any other XTV.
Jake: OK其实也不用我
Jake: OK, actually, we don't need...
Jake: 我就觉得就是
Jake: I just think that,
Jake: 可能就是最后一天放点背景墙
Jake: maybe on the last day, we can put up some background walls.
Jake: 上面放点照片得了
Jake: And put some photos on them.
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too.
Tasha: 我以为是要演电视剧
Tasha: I thought we were going to shoot a TV drama.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah,
Jake: 就是这种有剧情的短片
Jake: like a short film with a storyline.
Jake: 如果有的话就可以
Jake: If we have one, we can.
Jake: 其实就是世界地球日
Jake: Actually, it's Earth Day.
Jake: 可能这个迎接的时候可能放点PPT
Jake: Maybe during the reception, we can show some PPTs.
Jake: 放点电影
Jake: Show some movies.
Jake: 放点短片这种
Jake: Show some short films, stuff like that.
Jake: 然后明天可能就在户外玩一玩
Jake: And then maybe tomorrow we can play outside.
Jake: 拍一拍拉倒了对
Jake: Take some photos and call it a day, right?
Lucia: 是想拍一个vlog之类的吗
Lucia: Are you thinking of shooting a vlog or something?
Lucia: 还是什么
Lucia: Or what?
Jake: 那要不每人拍个vlog得了
Jake: How about everyone shoots a vlog?
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: Sure, that works.
Jake: 其实就是拍点户外的素材
Jake: Just film some outdoor footage.
Jake: 你们在户外
Jake: You guys outside...
Jake: 就是室内
Jake: Not inside...
Jake: 就不是室内的activity吧
Jake: Not an indoor activity, right?
Jake: 就是可能在河边走走啊
Jake: Maybe walk by the river or something.
Jake: 就就是做点素材吧
Jake: Just gather some footage.
Jake: 就是就我也不知道干什么
Jake: Honestly, I don't know what exactly.
Jake: 就是多拍照
Jake: Just take more photos.
Jake: 然后最后能放到最后一天就行
Jake: And then we can use them on the last day.
Jake: 在最后一天能够呈现
Jake: Present them on the last day.
Jake: 然后能演到今天就行
Jake: And it'll be enough for today.
Lucia: 所以我们最后一天到底需要有一个
Lucia: So, do we need to have a...
Lucia: 不是您指的这个剧本是什么意思
Lucia: What's the script you mentioned?
Lucia: 是我们这些天的活动的一个一个剧本
Lucia: Is it a script of our activities over these days?
Lucia: 然后在最后一天呈现吗
Lucia: And then present it on the last day?
Lucia: 只不过现在把这个idea pass掉了
Lucia: But now the idea is just passed.
Tasha: 他没有任何的剧本
Tasha: There isn't any script.
Jake: 对没有任何的剧本
Jake: Yeah, no script.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Just...
Lucia: 不是我一般以为team Lidar都是一个j人
Lucia: Usually, I thought the team leader had a person...
Jake: 哈哈哈因为这个就很火
Jake: Haha, because this is really popular.
Jake: 本身就是一个
Jake: It's basically a...
Jake: 叫什么生活类数据集
Jake: What's it called, a lifestyle dataset.
Jake: 对爱干啥都行
Jake: Do whatever you like.
Jake: 最后只要能联系上就行
Jake: As long as we can connect it at the end.
Tasha: 爱睡觉行吗
Tasha: Can I sleep?
Lucia: 加一
Lucia: Count me in.
Tasha: 哦爱打游戏行吗
Tasha: Oh, can I play games?
Jake: 那你得一边
Jake: Then you have to...
Jake: 你得跳着舞打
Jake: Dance while playing.
Lucia: 健身环哈哈哈
Lucia: Fitness Ring, haha.
Tasha: 健身房里面玩金铲铲啊
Tasha: Playing Golden Spatula in the gym?
Lucia: 没有我说的是switch那个健身环
Lucia: No, I meant the Fitness Ring on Switch.
Lucia: 哦不过健身房里玩也可以啊
Lucia: But playing in the gym works too.
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy it.
Lucia: 跑步机哈哈哈
Lucia: Treadmill, haha.
Jake: 对明天就
Jake: Yeah, tomorrow just...
Tasha: researcher
Tasha: Researcher.
Tasha: 在这里哈哈
Tasha: Over here, haha
Jake: 嗯好research
Jake: Hmm, okay, research
Jake: OK research
Jake: OK, research
Lucia: 我们有个地点吗
Lucia: Do we have a location?
Lucia: 周围有啥
Lucia: What's around?
Jake:对有个公园
Jake: Yeah, there's a park.
Lucia: 公园
Lucia: A park
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 有多大呀能玩一天吗哈哈哈
Lucia: How big is it? Can we spend the whole day there? Haha
Lucia: 我想了想户外
Lucia: I was thinking about outdoor activities
Lucia: hiking
Lucia: Hiking
Tasha: hiking
Tasha: Hiking
Tasha: 会被晒黑吧
Tasha: We might get tanned, right?
Tasha: 就喜欢公园能玩一天吗
Tasha: So you like parks, can we spend the whole day there?
Lucia: 我觉得这这么小的
Lucia: I think in such a small
Lucia: 村子应该
Lucia: Village, the park should
Lucia: 公园不是很大
Lucia: Not be very big
Lucia: 所以我们可以在公园里面再来一次
Lucia: So we can do another
Lucia: 破冰游戏
Lucia: Icebreaker game in the park
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:也可以啊
Jake: That works too
Tasha: 既然大家都是研究生了
Tasha: Since we're all grad students
Tasha: 那我们就玩一些
Tasha: Let’s play some
Lucia: 那我们就互相研究研究研究
Lucia: Let’s research each other, research, research
Lucia: 哦还可以
Lucia: Oh, that works too
Katrina:  我们开始扫了吗
Katrina: Are we starting to clean?
Jake: 对可以扫
Jake: Yes, we can clean
Jake: 是刚刚说什么研究生
Jake: What was that about grad students?
Lucia: 飞花令
Lucia: Feihualing
Katrina:  可以扫我房间
Katrina: We can clean my room
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my
Tasha: 你会玩吗
Tasha: Do you know how to play?
Jake: 害怕
Jake: Scared
Katrina:  什么飞花令
Katrina: What is Feihualing?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Katrina:  明天的游戏吗
Katrina: Is it tomorrow's game?
Lucia: 明天的游戏
Lucia: Tomorrow's game
Jake: 对明天再再琢磨整点啥
Jake: Yeah, we’ll think about it more tomorrow
Lucia: 可以是
Lucia: It could be
Lucia: 用古诗词飞吗
Lucia: Using ancient poetry for Feihualing?
Lucia: 还是飞什么别的东西
Lucia: Or fly something else?
Katrina:  古诗词我不行
Katrina: I can't do ancient poetry.
Tasha: 不然用什么飞
Tasha: What else would we fly?
Lucia: 哈哈这个这个
Lucia: Haha, this, this.
Lucia: 游戏不是
Lucia: Isn't it a game?
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Now
Lucia: 已经扩展到各种各样的游戏领域了
Lucia: It has expanded into all kinds of game fields.
Lucia: 好像吧
Lucia: Seems like it.
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For example, I can't come up with one.
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For example, I can't come up with one.
Lucia: 因为你问住我了
Lucia: Because you stumped me.
Tasha: 你说已经扩展到各个领域了
Tasha: You said it expanded into various fields.
Tasha: 我就想问问扩展到哪些领域了
Tasha: I just wanted to ask which fields it expanded into.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 就是好像现在也没有原来那么传统
Lucia: It's like now it's not as traditional as before.
Lucia: 就是比如说
Lucia: For example,
Lucia: 刚开始不是只有一
Lucia: At first, there was only one.
Lucia: 比如说就是花字带花字的
Lucia: For example, the ones with flowery text.
Lucia: 后来就变成什么什么意向的
Lucia: Later, it became something with all kinds of imagery.
Lucia: 或者说描述啥啥的那种都可以
Lucia: Or those that describe things, all kinds are okay.
Tasha: 哦哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Got it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 一会呃
Jake: In a bit, uh
Jake: 一会就是我要扫房间
Jake: In a bit, I need to sweep the room.
Jake: 然后你们可以
Jake: Then you guys can
Jake: 我先扫楼上
Jake: I'll sweep upstairs first.
Jake: 然后你们可以先下楼去讨论
Jake: Then you guys can go downstairs to discuss first.
Jake: 然后我扫楼下的时候你们再上来啊
Jake: Then when I sweep downstairs, you guys can come back up.
Tasha: 啊就是不能有人是吧
Tasha: Ah, so no one can be there, right?
Jake:就是我的
Jake: Exactly.
Jake: 手机的范围里面不能有人
Jake: No one can be within the range of my phone.
Lucia: 扫之前跟我说一声
Lucia: Let me know before you sweep.
Lucia: 因为我要把那边挂两件衣服拿出去
Lucia: Because I need to take out the two pieces of clothing hanging there.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Lucia: 那我要不然我还能挂着两件湿衣服很奇怪
Lucia: Otherwise, it would be weird if I keep hanging two wet clothes there.
Jake: 对对对那两件可能就哈哈哈
Jake: Right, right, those two pieces will, haha
Jake: 这就相当于是
Jake: It's like
Jake: 这个屋子里边固有的财产了
Jake: They would become part of the room's permanent property.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我就把它拿出来
Lucia: Hahaha, I just took it out.
Lucia: 然后就就就基本上只剩下箱子和包了
Lucia: And then basically only the box and the bag are left.
Lucia: 别的我都塞进去了
Lucia: I stuffed everything else in.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 成语接龙
Tasha: Word chain.
Lucia: 成语接龙现在可以
Lucia: We can play word chain now.
Tasha: 你画我猜
Tasha: Pictionary.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 我都可以
Lucia: I'm good with anything.
Lucia: 我是一个什么都可以的p人
Lucia: I'm a whatever-goes kind of person.
Tasha: 我在说一些很传统的游戏
Tasha: I'm talking about traditional games.
Lucia: 真心话大冒险
Lucia: Truth or Dare.
Lucia: 摇骰子也可以
Lucia: Rolling dice is fine too.
Lucia: 那赢的人喝
Lucia: The winner drinks.
Tasha: 输的人喝酒
Tasha: The loser drinks.
Lucia: 赢的人喝输的人也喝
Lucia: The winner drinks, the loser also drinks.
Lucia: 没有奖惩机制啊
Lucia: No reward and punishment system, huh?
Tasha: 我说输的人喝
Tasha: I said the loser drinks.
Lucia: 我以为是奖励赢的人喝
Lucia: I thought the winner drinks as a reward.
Lucia: 惩罚输的人喝酒呢
Lucia: Punish the loser by making them drink.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 怎么啦
Tasha: What's up?
Alice: 呵呵充电宝掉了
Alice: Haha, my power bank fell.
Tasha: 充电宝
Tasha: Power bank.
Alice: 这我腰里别着呢
Alice: I had it clipped to my waist.
Alice: 因为我没有兜
Alice: Because I don't have any pockets.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 没事我扶着呢你可以粘一粘好然后
Lucia: It's fine, I'll hold it for you. You can stick it back on.
Alice:你往上拎对
Alice: Pull it up, yeah.
Lucia: 可以这样吗
Lucia: Can it go like this?
Alice: 啊可以可以
Alice: Yeah, yeah, it works.
Alice:让我那个松紧带估着他
Alice: Let me use the elastic band to hold it.
Shure:  立定
Shure: Stand still.
Alice: 我把裙子往下拽让他估着就行
Alice: I'll pull my skirt down to hold it in place.
Lucia: 等一下我把他往外
Lucia: Wait, I'll pull it out.
Lucia: 哎别我捏着捏着充电宝给他捏
Lucia: Hey, no, I'm holding the power bank tightly.
Lucia: 关机了
Lucia: It turned off.
Alice: 算了给他弄弄掉吧不要了断了
Alice: Forget it, just let it drop. It's done.
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Lucia: 嗯好了
Lucia: Okay, done.
Alice: 不用了OK
Alice: No need, it's okay.
Lucia: 那我就先征用这个充电宝好了
Lucia: I'll just take this power bank for now.
Lucia: 我看一眼我那个还有多少电去拔线
Lucia: Let me check how much charge my device has and unplug it.
Katrina:  通州攻略哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Tongzhou guide, hahaha.
Katrina: 一天玩遍通州
Katrina: A day to explore all of Tongzhou.
Shure:  然后一搜全是环球影城
Shure: And when you search, it's all Universal Studios.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: That's hilarious.
Jake:就是一会的扫描活动都在吗
Jake: So, everyone's here for the scanning activity?
Jake: OK一会的扫描活动就是我在下面扫
Jake: Okay, for the scanning activity, I'll be scanning downstairs.
Jake: 然后我下面扫完之后
Jake: Then, after I finish scanning downstairs,
Jake: 呃我会躲在一个房间里面
Jake: I'll hide in a room.
Katrina:  然后我们去找你
Katrina: And then we come find you.
Jake: 然后我为了不扫到人
Jake: And to avoid scanning anyone,
Jake: 所以说我会在里面待着
Jake: I'll stay inside.
Jake: 然后我让刘帅下来叫你们
Jake: Then I'll have Choiszt come down and call you all.
Jake: 然后但是我不能扫到你们对吧
Jake: But I mustn't scan any of you, right?
Jake: 嗯所以说你们也要躲在一个房间里面
Jake: So, you guys need to hide in a room too.
Jake: 就你们得躲在就你们就躲在
Jake: Just hide, just hide...
Jake: 你们就在你们就室外吧
Jake: You can be outside, okay?
Jake: 好吧好对
Jake: Alright, yes.
Choiszt: 一楼扫完了他们不都去一楼都可以去一楼
Choiszt: Once the first floor is scanned, they can all go to the first floor.
Jake: 就是我上楼的时候不能扫到人
Jake: I can't scan anyone when I'm going upstairs.
Jake: 我上楼的时候你们在
Jake: When I'm going upstairs, you guys...
Jake: 对对对对嗯
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake: 然后你们在这就聊一聊明天的安排吧
Jake: Then you guys can discuss tomorrow's plans here.
Choiszt: 反正我叫他们下去他们就下去藏好
Choiszt: Anyway, when I call them down, they’ll hide well.
Jake: 对你们就你们
Jake: Yes, you guys...
Jake: 就就就出门就好
Jake: Just go out, it's fine.
Jake: 你们也可以
Jake: You can...
Jake: 现在在外边都都行
Jake: Stay outside, it's fine.
Jake: 总之就是我不能扫到人
Jake: Anyway, I mustn't scan anyone.
Jake: 你们聊一聊啊
Jake: You guys discuss.
Jake: 明天安排多多
Jake: Talk about tomorrow's plans.
Jake: 多交流多交流
Jake: Communicate more.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Jake: 多交流
Jake: Communicate more.
Jake: 反正明天大概是就是就是在户外
Jake: Anyway, tomorrow is basically going to be outdoors.
Jake: 然后加点压花什么的对吧
Jake: Then add some embossing or something, right?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Jake: 多说话啊多说话
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Nicous: 多说话那么简单我就一直跟你说
Nicous: If talking more was that simple, I'd always be chatting with you.
Shure:  多交流的方式是什么
Shure: What's a good way to communicate more?
Shure:  多喝酒就多
Shure: Drink more and...
Shure:  交流了哈哈
Shure: ...you'll communicate more, haha.
Lucia: 边喝边唠嗑啊
Lucia: Drink and chat at the same time.
Lucia: 那咱整两盅
Lucia: Let's have a couple of drinks then.
Katrina: 浓密延长其实都差不多了
Katrina: Thickening and lengthening are pretty much the same.
Katrina: 而且我估计你女朋友也不是很懂就截给你了
Katrina: And I guess your girlfriend doesn't really get it, so she just sent it to you.
Lucia: 我看一眼还有些啥
Lucia: Let me take a look at what else is here.
Lucia: 啥这是啥
Lucia: What's this, what is it?
Shure:  其实就是
Shure: Actually...
Shure:  刚才把你的橙汁换成了葡萄汁
Shure: I just switched your orange juice with grape juice.
Shure:  他基本就是只喝了一口而已
Shure: He basically just took one sip.
Lucia: 你不喝了吗
Lucia: You're not drinking anymore?
Tasha: 我不是你可以尝尝啊
Tasha: No, but you can try it.
Tasha: 我刚术后一个月内不能喝酒
Tasha: I can't drink for a month after my surgery.
Tasha:但是 我没有忍住然后喝了一点
Tasha: But I couldn't resist and had a little.
Tasha: 然后我慢慢喝就行
Tasha: So I'll just drink slowly.
Lucia: 我喝一下你介意吗
Lucia: Mind if I drink it?
Tasha: 不介意没事
Tasha: I don't mind, it's fine.
Lucia: 用同一个杯子
Lucia: Using the same cup?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Lucia: 那我就喝了
Lucia: Then I'll drink it.
Lucia: 其实我也不介意但是有的会介意一般会先问一下
Lucia: Actually, I don't mind, but some people do, so I usually ask first.
Lucia: 你这个屏幕好酷啊
Lucia: This screen of yours is so cool.
Lucia: 是像素哎
Lucia: It's pixelated, huh?
Tasha: 你看点他就会有羊然后你把羊给拖过来
Tasha: If you click on it, there'll be sheep, then you drag the sheep over.
Lucia: 那这些羊如果你很长时间不管他他会消失吗
Lucia: If you ignore the sheep for a long time, do they disappear?
Tasha: 不会
Tasha: No, they don't.
Lucia: 那你不断的点岂不是就会有很多很多的羊
Lucia: So if you keep clicking, there'll be a lot of sheep?
Tasha: 对然后可以跳到水里面
Tasha: Yes, and they can jump into the water.
Lucia: 哦是以这样的方式减少羊的数量吗
Lucia: Oh, is that how you reduce the number of sheep?
Tasha: 投河一只
Tasha: Throw one into the river.
Choiszt: 因为他一会要直接上来扫
Choiszt: Because he'll come up and clean it in a bit.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Got it.
Choiszt: 包括那边那个什么遥控器啥的拿一下
Choiszt: Also, take that remote over there.
Choiszt: 还有那个沙发上的东西也收一下
Choiszt: And tidy up the stuff on the sofa too.
Lucia: 这哎收哪去啊
Lucia: Hey, where should we put this?
Lucia: 这好像也没有袋子啥的可以给他
Lucia: Seems like there's no bag or anything to put it in.
Lucia: 藏靠垫后面吧
Lucia: Let's hide it behind the cushion.
Lucia: sorry靠垫是沾着的
Lucia: Sorry, the cushion is stuck.
Katrina: 他先把我拉黑的
Katrina: He blocked me first.
Katrina: 全平台拉黑
Katrina: Blocked me on all platforms.
Lucia: 靠
Lucia: Damn.
Shure: 你先把他拉黑一遍
Shure: You should block him back.
Lucia: 我就姑且认为这就算是藏好了
Lucia: I'll just assume it's well-hidden now.
Katrina: 我加都不想加好吗
Katrina: I don't even want to add him, okay?
Katrina: 他当时考完研还给我发短信呢
Katrina: He texted me after his exams.
Nicous:  他还有脸发短信
Nicous: He still had the nerve to text you.
Shure:  嗯就是
Shure: Exactly.
Katrina:  然后当时我就是属于呃
Katrina: At that time, I just didn't want to reply or block him.
Katrina:  就是不想回也不想拉黑
Katrina: Just didn't want to deal with it.
Katrina:  哦也有可能跟版本有关
Katrina: Oh, maybe it's related to the version.
Katrina:  但是这个牌子是日本牌子呀
Katrina: But this brand is Japanese.
Katrina: 差别不大啦女生看不出来吧
Katrina: There's not much difference, girls won't notice.
Shure: 确实
Shure: True.
Katrina: 明天一天都在外面吗
Katrina: Are we out all day tomorrow?
Katrina: 这还有佛教的东西
Katrina: There's also some Buddhist stuff.
Katrina: 我还要去雍和宫还个愿呢
Katrina: I still need to go to Yonghe Temple to fulfill a vow.
Katrina: 我觉得特别准当时求财运
Katrina: I think it's really accurate, I prayed for fortune.
Katrina: 财运还不错
Katrina: And my fortune's been good.
Nicous: 我都没求财运
Nicous: I didn't even pray for fortune.
Nicous: 我就应该去求财运
Nicous: I should have prayed for fortune.
Katrina: 当时我自己求的财运
Katrina: I prayed for my own fortune.
Katrina: 给我两个好朋友求的考研上岸
Katrina: And for two friends to pass their exams.
Katrina: 那两个都上岸了其他没上岸
Katrina: Both of them passed, the others didn't.
Shure: 完了我给我妹求的学业
Shure: I prayed for my sister's studies.
Katrina: 学业应该也还行
Katrina: Her studies should be fine too.
Nicous: 你是在雍和宫里面买的
Nicous: Did you buy it inside Yonghe Temple?
Nicous: 380
Nicous: For 380?
Katrina: 280这个是200
Katrina: 280, this one is 200.
Nicous: 你知道当时我是怎么买的吗我去
Nicous: Do you know how I bought mine? I went...
Nicous: 那个叫什么
Nicous: What's it called?
Katrina:  就是那个卖手串的集市是吧
Katrina: It's that market where they sell bracelets, right?
Nicous: 叫什么来着
Nicous: What's it called again?
Katrina: 叫什么来着三个字
Katrina: What's it called again, three characters.
Nicous: 对对对就里面好多卖眼镜的
Nicous: Yeah, yeah, the one with lots of glasses sellers.
Tasha: 潘家园
Tasha: Panjiayuan
Lucia: 哦想了半天
Lucia: Oh, I thought for a long time.
Shure:  潘家园跟北新桥离多远呢
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Beixinqiao?
Shure: 潘家园跟雍和宫离多远啊
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Yonghegong?
Nicous: 是远但是那边手串
Nicous: It's far, but the bracelets over there...
Katrina: 款式是一模一样的
Katrina: ...are exactly the same in style.
Nicous: 三十块钱一个
Nicous: Thirty yuan each.
Nicous: 然后买了
Nicous: So, I bought it.
Shure: 那他们能一样吗
Shure: Can they really be the same?
Nicous: 一模一样
Nicous: Exactly the same.
Katrina: 据说应该是有正版和盗版的区别的
Katrina: They say there should be a difference between genuine and fake ones.
Katrina: 但是这个心诚则灵还是买正版
Katrina: But if you believe, it works. Still, buy the genuine one.
Shure: 我需要充电我需要充电
Shure: I need to charge, I need to charge.
Katrina: 这充电宝没了吗
Katrina: Is this power bank out of juice?
Lucia: 这个呢哎这好像不是
Lucia: What about this one? Oh, this doesn't seem right.
Lucia: 这是这是啊我就说这好像不是公共充电宝
Lucia: This is... I was saying this doesn't seem like a public power bank.
Lucia: 你是手机还是眼镜要充电了
Lucia: Do you need to charge your phone or your glasses?
Lucia: 我刚好像在这看到
Lucia: I think I saw...
Lucia: 有一个
Lucia: ...one here.
Lucia: 不过这上面连不知道连着谁的线呢
Lucia: But it's connected to someone's cable.
Lucia: 眼镜的线
Lucia: Glasses' cable.
Katrina: 哇明天又是大晴天
Katrina: Wow, tomorrow's going to be sunny again.
Lucia: 啊这也是一个看一眼
Lucia: Ah, this one too, let me check.
Lucia: 哦这个没电了
Lucia: Oh, this one is out of battery.
Lucia: 这不能征用了
Lucia: We can't use this one.
Shure: 你滚啊
Shure: Get lost!
Katrina:  对就是睫毛打底是先
Katrina: Yes, for eyelash primer, you apply it first...
Katrina: 用睫毛打底再用睫毛膏
Katrina: ...then use mascara.
Katrina: 她给你的意思就是睫毛打底她也要
Katrina: She meant she wants eyelash primer too.
Katrina: 睫毛膏就买刚刚的那KISSME的
Katrina: Just buy the KISSME mascara we saw earlier.
Shure: 你好烦哦
Shure: You're so annoying.
Katrina:  这公园有那什么大摆锤什么的玩
Katrina: This park has those big rides like the pendulum.
Nicous:  他一般写预售都是规定的是吧
Nicous: Usually, the pre-sale is regulated, right?
Katrina: 应该是可以当天发
Katrina: It should be available on the same day.
Katrina: 因为他们基本上都是专柜采购的
Katrina: Because they usually source from the counters.
Katrina: 你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you guys coming tomorrow?
Nicous: 应该吧可能吧怎么说
Nicous: Maybe, not sure, what do you think?
Katrina:  他说就明天户外
Katrina: He said it's outdoor tomorrow.
Alice: 露西你见我的线了吗
Alice: Lucia, have you seen my cable?
Lucia: 呃在这里
Lucia: Uh, it's here.
Shure:  好困啊
Shure: I'm so sleepy.
Katrina:  我想洗澡呀
Katrina: I want to take a shower.
Shure: 洗过了
Shure: You already did.
Katrina:  就去西海子公园吧
Katrina: Let's go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  唱吧你就
Shure: Just sing, will you?
Katrina:  通利弗尼亚
Katrina: Tonifornia.
Katrina:  我真笑死
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter.
Alice: 你的手串
Alice: Your bracelet.
Katrina:  还可以划船呢
Katrina: We can even go boating.
Katrina:  哎北京好适合带富士相机
Katrina: Oh, Beijing is perfect for bringing a Fujifilm camera.
Shure:  是的我跟你讲
Shure: Yes, I'm telling you.
Tasha: 拍出来很好看
Tasha: The pictures turn out great.